SPREAD THE WORD.
THIS IS AN EMERGENCY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
1100 MILES EAST ALONG THE BORDER
IN TEXAS, THE CRISIS IS ALSO
TURNING DYER.
REPUBLICAN STATE LAWMAKERS
CALLING ON CONGRESS TO ACT WITH
ALL MEANS NECESSARY.
COME BACK FROM VACATION, PROVIDE
FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE SITUATION
AS HUNDREDS OF ILLEGALS FLOOD
THE BORDER THERE EVERY DAY.
JOINING ME NOW, TEXAS LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR DAN PATRICK.
DAN, CONGRESSMAN CASTRO BY THE
WAY IS SAYING THAT WASHINGTON
SHOULD BASICALLY BOUGHT OUT.
>> IT'S CLEAR THAT WE NEED
STRONGER LEADERSHIP IN THE STATE
TO STAND UP WHEN THE PRESIDENT
OR ANYONE ELSE IN WASHINGTON
TRIES TO MESS WITH TEXAS.
>> Laura: UNDRESSING YOU
BASICALLY THERE.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT, THE
TEXAS SENATE PASSED A RESOLUTION
A FEW WEEKS AGO CALLING A
CRISIS, CALLING IT AN EMERGENCY,
TELLING THE PRESIDENT TO DO
WHATEVER HE NEEDS TO DO.
LAURA, THESE PEOPLE ARE DENIERS
AND DECEIVERS.
EITHER THEY CAN FACE THE TRUTH
WITH A NOTE AND THEY ARE
DECEIVING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I LIKE THE IDEA THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE PUT OUT LAST WEEK
THE PRESIDENT PUT OUT, LET'S PUT
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
ACROSS ON AIRPLANES AND FLY THEM
TO SAN FRANCISCO, FLY THEM TO
NANCY PELOSI'S DISTRICT, THESE
DEMOCRATIC DISTRICTS THEY WILL
FIND OUT WHAT AN EMERGENCY AND A
CRISIS THIS IS WHEN THEIR
CONSTITUENTS COMPLAINT.
WASHING TAXES, WHY SHOULD
ARIZONA, WASHED WE BE THE BRUNT
OF THIS AND HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE CROSSING?
WHEN I WAS WITH YOU LAST WEEK
THE DAY I WAS WITH THE
PRESIDENT, I TALKED ABOUT
HOW WE FOUND 1671 DEAD BODIES OF
WOMEN, CHILDREN, ELDERLY WHERE
THE DRUG CARTELS BRING THE
PEOPLE ACROSS THE BORDER, LEAVE
THEM WITH NO WATER IN THE MIDDLE
OF NOWHERE TO DIE.
AND THE SEX TRAFFICKING.
TONIGHT THERE ARE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF YOUNG WOMEN ALL
OVER THIS COUNTRY WHO ARE BEING
FORCED INTO PROSTITUTION.
WE HAVE MODERN-DAY SLAVERY.
AND LAUREL, RIGHT NOW SOMEWHERE
IN TEXAS AND ELSEWHERE, THERE'S
A LITTLE GIRL CRYING BECAUSE SHE
IS TRAPPED IN A CANTINA HAVING
SEX WITH 20 MEN A DAY AND CAN'T
GET OUT.
SOMEONE ELSE THERE IS AN ELDERLY
PERSON DYING.
THEY ARE CRYING AND DYING AND
THEY NEED HELP AND THE DEMOCRATS
SAY THEY CARE ABOUT PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THESE
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: THEY CARE ABOUT
WINNING, POWER.
>> I CARE ABOUT AMERICAN LIVES
FIRST BUT IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
POWER.
>> Laura: YOU SPOKE OF PELOSI.
LISTEN TO WHAT PELOSI SAID
YESTERDAY ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
>> MAKE AMERICA MORE AMERICAN.
THIS PRESIDENT DECIDED TO USE IT
AS A CAMPAIGN TACTIC, AND THERE
ARE SOME FINANCIAL INSECURITIES
PEOPLE HAVE.
TRADE, IMMIGRANTS.
IT FOUND A MARKET.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE.
>> Laura: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
NEW FOX NEWS POLL JUST CAME OUT,
IMMIGRATION IS THE TOP ISSUE FOR
AMERICANS.
21%.
THEY KNOW IT HITS THEIR
POCKETBOOK.
ECONOMY, 10%.
HEALTH CARE, 9%.
CLIMATE CHANGE.
SORRY, BETO.
RACE RELATIONS, THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE IS IMMIGRATION.
IMAGINE IF THE MEDIA REALLY
REPORTED THAT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, LORELLE.
WHEN I HEAR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
FROM SOFT-SPOKEN NANCY LIKE SHE
SEEMS TO CARE, IT IS ALMOST
TREASONOUS WHAT SHE'S DOING.
SELLING OUT THIS COUNTRY.
I VIEW HER AS NOTHING MORE THAN
A SLAVEHOLDER BECAUSE SHE'S IN
CHARGE OF NOT HELPING THESE
PEOPLE, THESE POOR YOUNG GIRLS,
THESE POOR YOUNG GIRLS.
THEY ARE TRAPPED IN CANTINA'S
AND BARS ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY.
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS AND I
TELL YOU WHAT.
I'M GOING TO PUT OUT $100,000
BOUNTY RIGHT TONIGHT ON YOUR
SHOW.
I WILL GIVE ANY DEMOCRAT $10,000
TO THEIR FAVORITE CHARITY.
COME DOWN TO TEXAS AND GO OUT IN
NO-MAN'S-LAND WITH ME WHERE
THESE CARTELS DROP OFF THESE
PREGNANT WOMEN, THESE CHILDREN,
OLD PEOPLE, AND THEY DIE.
COME WITH ME, DEMOCRATS.
COME FROM RHODE ISLAND OR
WHATEVER STATE YOU WANT TO BE
FROM WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE A CLUE
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
I WILL TAKE THEM OUT AND I WILL
GIVE THEM AN HALF A GALLON OF
WATER AND SEE HOW LONG THEY LAST
AND THEY ARE GOING TO REALIZE
IT'S A CRISIS AND I WILL TAKE
THEM TO A CANTINA WHERE WE JUST
ROUNDED UP 59 YOUNG GIRLS
RECENTLY AND BEFORE WE CAN HELP
THEM, THE DRUG CARTEL LAWYERS
ARE THERE TO SPRING THEM.
THEY ARE SCARED TO DEATH TO SAY
ANYTHING.
THIS IS A CRISIS OF UNBELIEVABLE
PROPORTIONS.
>> Laura: PETE BUTTIGIEG, PETE
BUTTIGIEG, SOUTH BEND IS IN
FULL.
ALL OF YOU PEOPLE SAYING THE
COUNTRY IS FULL, SOUTH BEND IS
NOT FULL.
YOU HAVE 102,000 PEOPLE IN
SOUTH BEND.
THIS MONTH WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
100,000 PEOPLE CROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY.
>> WE WILL TAKE HIM TO HIS TOWN.
I'M SERIOUS.
ANY DEMOCRAT WHO WANTS TO COME,